salut romain ça va bof fut double
malades double malades
oui j'ai un truc des virus peuvent tuer
les bactéries ouais donc et donc comme
j'avais une angine g lécher la barre du
métro pour choper un virus et donc est
donc maintenant j'ai une angine et une
gastro barret non non c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe
on ya quelques temps que je vous
raconterai comment certaines bactéries
étaient devenues résistantes aux
antibiotiques et qu'il fallait qu'on se
bouge si on voulait pas se retrouver
sans défense face à elle parce qu'elles
sont responsables de 33 mille morts par
an en europe
sept cent mille dans le monde et que si
on fait rien ça pourrait monter à 10
millions de morts par an en 2050
non mais revenez il ya des solutions
d'ailleurs dans cette même vidéo je vous
disais aussi et il faut aussi trouver
d'autres moyens de lutter contre les
infections et là dessus la recherche a
aussi des pistes voilà il ya des pistes
donc vous voyez ça va vous êtes émotif
quand même
aujourd'hui on va justement parlé d'une
de ces pistes les bactériophages
bactériose c'est pour bactéries les
phages ça veut dire manger des mangeurs
de bactéries bon endroit et vous avez
accès parce qu'ils leur font on a péri
quand c'est pas vraiment les manger au
final c'est des tueurs de bakker et on
va pas chipoter pour être très clair
l'idée ce n'est pas de remplacer les
antibiotiques c'est de trouver un moyen
de soigner les infections causées par
des bactéries sur lesquels les
antibiotiques ne marche plus mais vous
avez contre les bactériophages on dit
aussi les phages même si ça veut juste
dire manger et que en bon c'est un peu
les prédateurs naturels des bactéries et
des virus pour bactéries et il s'attaque
qu'aux bactéries on les trouve comme ça
dans l'environnement et il empêche les
bactéries de proliférer de façon
naturelle et ça fait un moment qu'on les
connaît puisqu'ils ont été décrits en
1915 par un chercheur anglais
frédéric thouars avant que le franco
canadien tmx d'airelles pense à les
utiliser pour soigner des infections
chez les humains c'est à dire avant
qu'il invente la phagothérapie le
traitement par l'eba cariou alors vous
allez me dire ok donc on connaît ce truc
depuis plus d'un siècle depuis avant les
antibiotiques mais on utilise pas quel
est le fuck et je vais vous répondre
bien vu mais cette pas trop les malins
en fait les recherches sur les
bactériophages elles ont été laissés de
côté au profit des antibiotiques
notamment parce que il était plus facile
à produire en quantité industrielle et
qu'on en avait besoin pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale du coup c'est assez
cocasse de voir qu'aujourd'hui on les
relance parce qu'on n'est pas loin de
l'impasse avec ces mêmes antibiotiques
et sexy c'est cocasse non
et puis en réalité ces recherches elles
n'ont pas été laissés de côté par tous
parce que en europe de l'est vu que
c'était un peu compliqué trouver des
antibiotiques pendant un moment il
maison continue donc la phagothérapie ça
existe toujours dans certains pays comme
la géorgie ou la pologne par exemple il
ya même des français qui vont se faire
soigner là bas mais avant de voir
comment on pourrait se faire prescrire
par notre médecin comment ça marche en
fait alors à bactériophages ça ressemble
à sa venue
le problème de cette petite bête c'est
que elle peut pas se reproduire tout
seul entendue non plus mais le
bactériophages ne peut pas non plus se
reproduire avec un autre individu de son
espèce
pour que la réplication puisse se faire
il a besoin d'une bactérie dans laquelle
il peut injecter son arn ou son adn
et ça tombe bien parce qu'il en a plein
la tête juste là de l'adn plein la tête
boutique de dollars
[Musique]
du coup quand il a trouvé la bonne
bactéries il s'accroche sur ces
récepteurs il lui perfore la paroisse et
la membrane et paf il injection
d'intérêt gênés en suit la réplication
se fait à l'intérieur de la bactérie qui
finit par exploser
en gros en libérant des nouveaux
bactériophages et ça continue jusqu'à ce
qu'ils aient plus à ces bactéries pour
qu'ils fassent leurs petites affaires et
qu'ils soient éliminés par l'organisme
par les voies habituelles c'est à dire
le foie et les reins
l'avantagé c'est qu'ils s'attaquent à un
type de bactérie bien précis donc ils
tuent pas toutes les autres qui nous
sont utiles et il s'attaque qu'aux
bactéries pas à nos cellules
parce qu'ils sont équipés que pour se
fixer sur les récepteurs des bactéries
qui leur permettent de se multiplier
alors tout ça c'est bien joli mais c'est
disponible dans certains pays et pas en
france
parce que les règles pour utiliser un
traitement c'est pas les mêmes dans tous
les pays est pour l'instant en europe de
l'ouest et aux etats-unis et c'est la
phagothérapie n'a pas encore reçu
l'autorisation pour l'instant et oui
parce que je voulais dit ça redevient
d'actualité en france par exemple il ya
une société de biotechnologie qui
s'appelle ferrer side qui a repris les
recherches pour obtenir ces fameuses
autorisation le problème c'est que ce
type de recherche
ça prend du temps et surtout ça coûte
énormément d'argent et la bim
l'union européenne a fait chauffer la cb
et elle finance la recherche
donc c'est reparti alors vous allez me
dire pourquoi l'union européenne parce
que les bactéries les frontières s en
foutent
donc si on veut lutter contre
l'antibiorésistance c'est mieux si
chacun bosse pas dans son compte si vous
voulez en savoir plus je vous mets dans
la description le lien vers le site de
la campagne une veste lui qui explique
ça très bien mais concrètement comment
ça se passe le boulot des chercheurs ça
a d'abord été de sélectionner les
bactériophages pour garder que les plus
efficaces et de les trier en fonction
des types de bactéries auxquels ils
s'attaquent ensuite il a fallu les
produire ces petits champions ça prend
deux à trois mois pour fabriquer un lot
rien que ça c'est long et pour finir ils
ont créé une espèce de bibliothèque
sauf que c'est pas des livres cd flacon
de la carriole fages et c'est pas des
étagères c'est des armoires réfrigérées
ça a l'air de rien mais tout ça c'est
très long parce qu'il faut tout faire
dans les règles de l'art et
on l'a vu les règles elles sont strictes
et tant mieux maintenant il faut obtenir
les autorisations soient des
autorisations temporaires d'utilisation
pour des cas très précis soit une
autorisation de mise sur le marché
mais avant ça il faut faire des études
cliniques et ça aussi ça a déjà démarré
alors attention on va pas vous donner
des bactériophages pour soigner votre
petit otites ou votre angine bactérienne
encore une fois on parle de traitement
exceptionnel qui marche sur des
bactéries résistantes et qui sont
utilisées quand aucun autre traitement
n'est efficace dans le cadre du projet
dont je vous parle ça a par exemple été
utilisé pour soigner des infections sur
la peau des grands brûlés qui sont
particulièrement vulnérables
les premiers traitements pourraient
arriver ni 2019 ils ont déjà permis
cette année de guérir six patients qui
avaient des infections au niveau des
eaux ou des articulations et chez qui
tous les autres traitements avaient
choqué tout ça c'est un peu abstrait
concrètement comment ça se passe une
femme aux thérapies j'en ai parlé avec
le boss de faire un site qui m'a décrit
la façon dont ça se déroule et en gros
ça donne ça un patient à une infection
et aucun traitement traditionnel
fonctionne parce que la bactérie en
cause elle est résistante aux
antibiotiques ont fait un prélèvement au
niveau de l'infection et on l'envoie au
labo pour qu'il puisse trouver les
bactériophages les plus efficaces sur ce
type de bactéries
une fois qu'il les a sélectionnés le
labo prépare les bactériophages et ils
les envoient à la pharmacie de l'hôpital
qui soigne le patient ensuite la
pharmacie dilue tout ça en fonction du
cas du patient pour les brûlures par
exemple il va falloir imprégné des
pansements et les poser directement sur
la zone à traiter mais dans le cas
d'infection ostéo-articulaires c'est à
dire les os et les articulations
il faut parfois qu'un chirurgien ouvre
pour bien laver avec le liquide et
laisser directement au contact de
l'infection donc on parle d'un
traitement qui va être fabriqué
individuellement en fonction du cade
chaque patient et de la bactérie en
cause et qui va être utilisé comme
traitement de la dernière chance quand
tout le reste a échoué
et en plus des cas qu'on a déjà cité ça
pourrait permettre de soigner des
infections graves au niveau des pieds
chez les diabétiques sont
particulièrement exposées ou des
infections respiratoires ou au niveau du
coeur par exemple si les recherches ont
repris dans plusieurs pays du monde si
l'union européenne a investi dedans
c'est parce qu'on a pris conscience de
l'impasse dans laquelle on se trouve
face aux bactéries multi
et que pour éviter de donner raison aux
prévisions dont je parlais en début de
vidéo pour mieux pas attendre 2050
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]